less than 24 hours ago another officer
involved shooting this one in North Las
Vegas the family of the man shot and
killed speaking out he has been
identified as 44 year old Christopher
Earl Smith the incident occurred near
MLK and Carey that's where we find
Victoria Saha live with reaction from
the family Victoria
police say the incident started right
here by the north Las Vegas Justice
Center when a man pulled a gun on
someone the police say he then went
across the street still showing his
weapon and then he came right back here
where police shot and killed him
a candle now sits on the bench by the
Justice Center where family of
Christopher Smith says he would spend a
lot of his time that was a real family
man and he cared about his family a lot
the Justice Center is where I met
Shanika Fitzgerald she tells me she
doesn't think the police needed to shoot
her cousin my cousin was a good guy all
you had to do was literally sit there
and talk to him and he would elicit
according to North Las Vegas Police they
received a call saying a man had pulled
a gun on him by the Justice Center then
the man went to the car wash and was
pointing the gun at people while wearing
a Halloween mask another call came in
from the Carrie Mini Mart saying the
same man was threatening customers and
when he walked back to the Justice
Center it was at this location where
officers say they told him to drop his
weapon he did not listen and officers
say he pulled a gun from his waistband
this is when officers shot and killed
him so the incident that police are
describing that happened does that sound
like her cousin at all not at all
that's why I want to see cameras I got
to
even listening to the stories from
people that it was never on his face
like he was walking back across the
street with his drink
Smith's family says the condition of his
body is making them believe that he was
shot multiple times but we reached out
to North Las Vegas Police they haven't
commented on exactly how many times
Smith was shot reporting from North Las
Vegas tonight Victoria Saha 8 News Now